une longue matinée d'audition je dois
dire qu'elle s'est déroulée dans un
cadre parfaitement coopératif et avec la
même sérénité que l'ensemble des
auditions que nous avons déjà conduite
nous en sommes maintenant à 25 auditions
et nous allons poursuivre notre travail
le moment n'est pas venu de vous livrer
des conclusions puisque nous n'avons
même pas eu le temps je suis avec les
deux rapporteurs jean pierre sueur et
muriel jourda nous n'avons même pas eu
le temps de débriefer comme on dit
aujourd'hui
7 cette matinée d'audition et simplement
ce que nous observons c'est que les
contradictions qui sont apparues sur la
définition de la fonction réelle de
monsieur benalla dès le début de nos
auditions au mois de juillet ne sont pas
levés aujourd'hui elles sont d'autant
moins que il y a eu nous pourrions dire
une définition assez évolutive de cette
fonction l'organisation des déplacements
privés la participation à l'organisation
des déplacements publics
la participation à l'organisation des
invitations pour le 14 juillet s'est
ajoutée la semaine dernière la
coordination de commandement militaire
du palais et deux du groupe de sécurité
du président de la république
nous comprenons que l'ajout de cette
mission de coordination de la sécurité
était un argument aussi pour justifier
un permis de port d'armes qui ne pouvait
se justifier que par une fonction de
sécurité mais nous avons appris
aujourd'hui de la bouche de monsieur
benalla que au fond cet arme n'était pas
destiné à l'exercice de sa fonction mais
à sa protection personnelle ce que
l'ancien chef du cabinet du préfet de
police a paru confirmer et du coup
subsiste quand même pour nous beaucoup
d'interrogations sur ces différents
ponts monsieur le président
nos travaux en tout en toute sérénité ce
monsieur présent à l'instant benjamin
griveaux le porte parole du gouvernement
attaqué votre déontologie il vous accuse
de manquer déontologie qu'est ce que
vous lui répondez à benjamin griveaux
ignorait que monsieur benjamin griveaux
fut professeur de déontologie et par
conséquent
laissons lui la responsabilité de ces
propos nous nous essayons de travailler
en dehors de toute cette agitation
politicienne et nous allons poursuivre
aussi sereinement que nous l'avons fait
dans les premières semaines notre
travail qui est un travail qui est
destiné à s'assurer du bon
fonctionnement de services publics
essentiels la protection du président de
la république dans notre pays doit
répondre aux meilleurs standards
internationaux il ne faut pas qu'elle
soit perturbé par des interférences
d'agents qui quelles que soient leurs
qualités viendrait
apporter des éléments de difficultés
dans cette protection de même que les
voyages présidentiels situe le atteinte
en situe le permet je voulais dire par
rapport à ce que vous apprenez des
déclarations de monsieur griveaux que
avec muriel jourda et avec la totalité
des membres de la commission je crois
pouvoir le dire ici présents nous
désapprouvons totalement ce genre de
déclarations à l'encontre de notre
président je le dis moi et je sais que
muriel jourda partage totalement alors
et noir non mais pourquoi parce que tous
les français qui ont écouté ce matin
nos auditions ont pu voir le climat de
respect dans lequel cela s'est produit
monsieur benalla a présenté ses excuses
ce matin et il a répondu à l'ensemble
des questions c'est la vérité et je
termine en disant que nous avons bien
compris bien compris que certaines
personnes sont très vigilantes quant à
la séparation des pouvoirs entre le
pouvoir législatif et la justice le
pouvoir judiciaire
mais nous pouvons leur répondre que nous
sommes également extrêmement attentif à
la séparation des pouvoirs entre le
pouvoir législatif et le pouvoir
exécutif que le pouvoir exécutif laisse
le parlement
en l'espèce le cdh à faire son office et
tout ira bien dans la république
je vous remercie